i'm going to share with you my plan to
get to a billion dollars a year in
revenue and i'm going to answer the
number one question that i get most
frequently which is why we don't sell
courses and why i give our stuff away
for free
without further ado let's rock and roll
so my name is alex mosey for those who
are new to the channel i own
acquisition.com it's a portfolio of
companies that does about 85 million a
year in revenue like i said i have
nothing to sell you and the reason for
that is because those companies pay for
all the stuff that i have already and i
don't think selling a thousand dollar
course is really going to be that
meaningful to me so that being said
the exciting news um is why we are doing
this and what you have to gain from it
in growing acquisition.com the portfolio
companies we've acquired a lot of skills
along the way so uh how to create offers
how to generate leads how to monetize
your acquisition so you can get
customers for free how to sell how to
scale sales teams how to increase
lifetime gross profit per customer how
to price adequately like the beliefs
around it how to exit the business all
of these different things at this point
we've already sold seven businesses in
my career we have six i think right now
in our portfolio companies we continue
to uh want to acquire more and so my
entire thesis behind acquisition.com and
stay tuned because you're gonna like the
thing that i'm giving you at the end
it's gonna be sick and it's gonna be
worth a lot of stuff to get on the
internet the reason that i do
acquisitions.com the thesis behind it is
that i believe the education system is
broken and many of you probably agree
with me right who wants to pay fifty
thousand hundred thousand two hundred
thousand dollars a year
right for an education that adds zero
value if you can get the same job at the
same pay before you go in as you can get
after you go to college then what's the
point right and not only that because
it's government subsidized they don't
let you get out of the debt which is
insane to me in what world would you
give an 18 year old 200 000 they can
never get out of right it's like making
an irreversible decision and and they do
that because they saddle you with debt
and they take 35 of your paycheck for
the rest of your life and you don't know
that but they're doing it through
interest all right anyways that being
said
enter acquisition.com the reason i
believe that this explosion of the guru
space has happened over the last 10 15
years is because the demand for high
value skills has not changed people want
to work by and large people want to
provide value people want to be good at
something and exchange their time and
effort and knowledge for money right but
the thing is is they're not getting the
skills and so they continue to seek and
the demand is there it is just
unsatisfied and so because of technology
right because of the changes in the
world technology and i'll quote nova all
rivaks i like this quote a lot
technology democratizes consumption and
consolidates production and what that
means is if you're the best in the world
you get to do it for everyone and so my
thesis around acquisitions.com is that
education will become increasingly
fragmented meaning rather than one big
glop of general education people are
going to get more and more niche down in
the types of education that they learn
they'll learn how to become hairdressers
they'll learn how to become plumbers
they'll learn how to run gyms they'll
learn how to be online trainers learn
how to be life coaches to learn how to
do whatever you know fix atm machines
whatever it is there are skills that are
niche and more high value that they can
exchange in the marketplace for money
and they can feed themselves and so my
goal with acquisition.com is to give the
thing that i have that is more valuable
than money for those who who do follow
our channel my wife and i donate about a
million dollars a year right now of a
personal income and we've already signed
away our wills that we will be donating
the vast majority of our of our dollars
to charities upon our death the thing is
is that as much as i i can give money
the thing that i can give at far more
leverage and at far more scale is the
skills that we have acquired in order to
create that money and i can do that at
zero cost and so that is the thesis
behind this is that i want to take all
the skills that i have and transfer them
to everyone else and
the idea here is that i can help as many
people get to 1 million 3 million 5
million a year and then maybe someday if
it's awesome if you're at 5 or 10 or 15
or 20 and you'd like to get to 50
million you'd like to get 100 million
you'll allow us to to help and and
invest in your business so we can do it
together otherwise everything we have is
free um and today mark's a very
important announcement that i have for
everyone on the channel moseynation love
you all and it's for you guys the first
of 10 different courses at least at this
point i have 10 that are outlined that i
will be releasing with books and audio
books and downloads to go with it so the
first is uh 100 million offers this is a
book you can get it on amazon for 99
cents go grab it if you want the hard
copy i think it says i think this is
like 20 bucks uh but it's full colorful
print and that i make i think a dollar
on this all right and i donated all the
stuff to charity anyways so you can get
that and then on the site um you can get
the downloads and all that stuff you
don't have to opt in anything you can
just click and download it has all the
checklists all the sops everything that
we do to actually do this within our
businesses all right you can just have
them and then we will be releasing all
of the videos that you can find on the
site you'll also find them here on
youtube as one playlist alright so you
can watch them uninterrupted no purchase
necessary nothing and this is why i do
this for free is because candidly
i
have gotten to a point where
money only solves money problems and
i have solved all of my money problems
and what remain are problems that money
can't solve and so uh in an attempt to
solve the problems that money can't
solve which for me our meaning uh
meaning in life if i know that i'm going
to be giving away everything that i have
when i die it sounds silly to not enjoy
that giving process while i'm alive
and to give the thing that is more
valuable the most valuable thing that i
have which are the skills and the
beliefs that i've acquired that have
gotten us here which i believe that
anyone
can acquire those skills those traits
and beliefs if they want to and so i
want to make that available to everyone
and anyone who has that desire and so
that is uh the reason that i wrote the
book that is the reason that we have the
courses and that is the reason that i
will continue to do this because i
really like it and so um i love you all
um i am your number one fan i'm rooting
for you more than you can imagine um and
because i know that when i die
eventually on a long enough time horizon
all of the money and wealth that our
companies will amass will eventually get
scattered to the wind and the legacy
that i will leave will eventually be
forgotten and so i might as well enjoy
the ride with you all that stuff will
now be live uh i will keep you guys
posted as we as we release new courses
and books uh please don't ask when
they're coming out the the litmus test
for when i will release it is when it is
good enough to be better than the thing
that you just had and so i always want
to make it better and better and better
and the difference between good and
great is vast and the difference between
vast sorry the difference between great
and exceptional or remarkable is even
wider and it takes time to have several
coats of paint on work and let it sit
and let it marinate and let it simplify
and distill so that i can try and
transfer the knowledge as quickly and as
seamlessly from me to you as possible in
a way that is not boring as hell and so
that is my goal all right and so uh at
this point uh the courses that will be
coming out are first uh the one that is
now live is the 100 million dollar
offers course how to make offers so good
people feel stupid saying no so right
now if you struggle to sell you struggle
to get leads things like that it's
because usually your offer is poor right
so if you're not good at sales a lot of
times the thing that you're actually
selling people don't want and there's
ways to structure the offer so way more
people will buy it all right this is one
of the cornerstone pillars and i had
some of the other courses already
outlined and written but i realized i
had to do this first all right so i'm
teaching these courses in sequence for
how you would do it to improve and build
your business the second course and book
will be around lead generation so once
you have the offer the thing that you're
going to sell that people want it's how
do i get more leads all right so i'll
show you the ways that we get leads in
all the companies across all different
channels and the processes that we
follow to do that the next one after
that will be called money models all
right so it's how you can grow without
outside capital all right so we've been
able to grow each of these businesses
that we have without any outside capital
because we use a process called client
finance acquisition which basically
means that we use the money from the
marketplace to fund our own growth so we
have a negative acquisition cost it
means it costs us less money to get a
customer than than we make in it getting
it all right and we can collect more
than that in 30 days of cash so we can
continue to reinvest in acquisition so
the acquisition is no longer a
bottleneck which leaves us naturally the
next thing which is sales so i'll show
you how to script the sales process
choreograph the process and the words
and all that kind of stuff that'll be
the next book all right the book after
that be scaling sales teams all right
because that's a whole nother skill is
scaling the actual team and recruiting
and compensation and management and
training all that stuff and that's what
really builds big enterprises
after that we'll go into uh pricing and
increasing lifetime gross profit per
customer so how do you actually do that
in a way that is operationally efficient
all right and so we've done this in a
lot of companies it's one of the things
that we do very well because the back
end ultimately informs the front and the
more money you make per customer the
more that you can ultimately uh spend on
acquisition and then scale the company
as a result of that and at the end of
the day the product is always going to
be the number one thing that ultimately
would determine the success of the
company people think it's about the
marketing if you want to if you want to
make a little bit of money sure learn
how to promote learn how to market like
i mean anyone can sell anything to
somebody once right but the guys who
build fortunes learn how that once they
make a sale they make a sale to get a
customer they don't get customers to
make sales think about that for a second
you make a sale to create the
relationship of a customer that then
buys again and again and again and again
built on the trust and the value that
you've provided in excess of the price
that they paid right people pay right
for the discrepancy between what they
pay and what they get right that is the
value that is the customer surplus that
is where they feel like they got a good
deal and so a good deal has nothing to
do with the price but everything to do
with the value and so my goal here with
everything that i have is that i'm
pricing this at zero
so that hopefully you get the most value
humanly possible and so anyways
moseynation i do this stuff for you guys
um i do this because candidly i enjoy it
i had an executive coach a while back
when i was kind of feeling like i didn't
have any meaning there was just lots of
money that was plowing in every week and
i was like i don't know what i want to
do and she was like what do you enjoy
doing and i was like well i enjoy
reading i enjoy writing uh and i enjoy
uh transferring the skills that i have
to other people and i like drawing the
frameworks out so that um i learn in
teaching and she was like well how can
you design uh you know a life around
that
and so i went to work and that was about
a year and a half ago um was where the
kind of the idea for acquisition.com
started um and i was like i want to help
entrepreneurs in general and i want to
do it in a way that no one else is doing
it so that is um
that's why i'm doing this and so uh yeah
my goal is that if you're if you're if
you're new entrepreneur and you're you
know trying to make your first dollar
first million or fifth million whatever
it is um that we can help you along the
way and long term if you ever want us to
invest in your business if you cross the
5 million ish threshold you're 5 or 10
or 15 and you'd like to get to 30 or 50
or 100
then you'll allow us that that fun
opportunity with you but otherwise uh
everything we have is free uh mosey
nation i have nothing to sell you keep
being awesome and i'll see you guys in
the videos